so I'm here with Sean Logan who's a
director of College counseling at
Phillips Andover Academy and Jim ventra
Ventre am i pronouncing it right Jim
venturi yes curry who's the director of
admissions and financial aid at Phillips
Andover and what we're hoping to talk or
start talking about in this video is is
really just a financial aid prop process
and in particular the FAFSA so I guess I
should probably do that in all caps my
first question for either of you is I
guess what is the FAFSA and what it was
it actually stand for right so the FAFSA
is the Free Application for Federal
Student Aid and it's really important
for students to realize that free part
of this name because there are there is
an opportunity to get on the web and go
to FAFSA calm and somebody will happily
help you with it but you need to pay for
it so the first thing we talk with
students a lot about is the FAFSA is a
free form you should not be paying for
it and as and the title again it's by
the federal government they use a rubric
to sort of figure out based on this form
how much your family should contribute
to a college education did I get that
it's free application for federal
student student yes
yep made and and just to hit the point
home of what you just said it should
absolutely be free and there are places
where the people will charge you to kind
of optimize it or fill it out for you or
it's correct so and so the first thing
normally when you start to type in if
you you know start to type in on a
search engine FAFSA a lot of times
fafsa.com pops up it's a legitimate site
but they charge you something like
eighty eighty five dollars to fill help
you fill out the form so you want to go
to fafsa.ed.gov to start this process
ed gov and there will be free and and
what is you know when you fill out this
form in a future videos will actually
take a look at the form itself but but
what I guess you know what do you input
into it and what comes out of it and who
uses that information I think the for
many students who are applying to
college right now they are accustomed to
telling their story in essays and in
various pieces of their application and
they have to think of the FAFSA as just
the their family's financial story and
financial story has many variables but
most importantly the things that the
FASFA asked for are simplified as things
that would be questions that students
could probably answer right off the top
of their head in terms of their family
income and whether they own a home or
whether they rent where they live it's
things like that and I mean I remember
filling those and we were talking about
this before I guess clicking record all
of us I guess where were significant
recipients of financial aid of
need-based financial aid and I remember
filling it out I remember I kind of had
my mom's tax for which I had to fill out
for right before filling out the FAFSA
exactly but but that's essentially I
remember at least this was in the early
90s kind of the inputs that that I
needed to be able to fill out most of
the form and that's correct yeah I mean
one of the things that you know
specifically looking at and working with
a lot of low-income families one of the
things to realize is is that it
generally is actually a pretty simple
form because there aren't a lot of
things that make it complicated there
aren't trust funds there aren't
investments there aren't probably a lot
of times sometimes there are homes that
are owned but a lot of times they're
just renting usually it's a paycheck
that comes in and it's a sort of a
standard you know paycheck that comes in
for the year so it's a it's actually a
pretty simple form it's just getting
students to step up and do it is it's a
real challenge and and the reason
obviously it's pretty obvious why they
care about income that's kind of you
know just the total amount of money your
family's making but then the reason why
they care about things like home
ownership and if I remember properly you
know they remember they ask things about
the number of siblings you have and they
try to understand your family's expenses
too and the whole reason is to kind of
figure out their ability to pay for
college that's right so at the at the
outset students are asked questions to
fill out and their family's financial
circumstances that basically what the
colleges are trying to do is come to a
conclusion which allows them to have a
picture of what the what the family is
up against every month every week and
what's at what's left in the bank so to
speak at the end of all the family
operating expenses and so what after you
fill out the form you know where does
that go does this is at the Department
of Education site
but do they process it or they just give
the form to the universities what what
happens after that
yeah that's a great points out I think
one of the misperceptions about the
FAFSA is I'm going to submit this form
to the government basically and then
they're gonna crunch all these numbers
and then they're going to determine a
financial aid package for my family I
think that's a really common
misperception what the FAFSA all the
FAFSA does is it looks at again your
family's income number of kids in the
family other assets those sorts of
things and it determines an estimated
Family Contribution what a college does
with that varies greatly and I think
that's something that you know families
need to understand so it also all of
this going to do is determine a number
that number might mean you know your
family should be able to contribute
$1,000 towards it towards your son or
daughter's education $5,000 or $0 for
that matter but that's all it does I see
and the reason why this I guess exists
is so that colleges would have somewhat
a somewhat uniform way of looking at
this and they can feel good that the
data is I guess real that's right and so
one of the things in this estimated
Family Contribution is sort of this the
sense that the family is self reporting
where they stand in their family
circumstances financially and one of the
things we want to caution about is that
when you receive a sort of estimated
Family Contribution or what they call
the EFC you want to make sure that's in
line with your expectations because
sometimes that number can seem odd for
the family when they when they
understand where it came from and they
may have made a mistake in some way on
the form I see
but then that estimated Family
Contribution then that gets sent to the
universities that you have usually at
this point have gotten admission to well
it'll go to every every University
ahead of time so you know if the student
applies to seven schools you're gonna
want it there well before decisions come
out they're usually very strict
deadlines to get things there in time
but then usually what happens in
admissions office is if you know Sal if
I'm reading your application in the
admissions office and I say great Sal
Khan is gonna be admitted I call down to
our financial aid office this is all
done electronically now but you know the
financial aid officer what he will do is
open up your electronic file and he will
see the FAFSA sitting in there and then
you will see that it
say okay you know the the Khan family
should be able to pay you know $1,000
towards Sal's education we cost $50,000
so now we're gonna have to create a
financial aid package for $49,000 to
make it possible for you to come here
and and so that's before you've been
officially admitted typically it's it's
typically when you get admitted then the
admissions office will say okay now
calculate a financial aid package and
and are these you know I can imagine a
lot of students would worry about this
are these kind of separate processes
you know if or will the admissions
officers be able to see the kind of
estimated Family Contribution and does
that have the potential to kind of
affect your your chances of admissions
oh absolutely I think that colleges are
mindful of the programs that they have
in place to support these students and
so the the college's overall mission
plays a role in how they're distributing
financial aid and the way they view
students that they're going to support
through what they uncover in the FAFSA
and Sal let me add to that this is too
important
I think definitions here one is
institutions that are neat blind and
institutions that are needs sensitive
and that's an important question for
students to ask as they're starting to
research colleges typically need blind
schools mean you know whether or not
you're applying for aid has no impact on
an admissions decision and we will fund
you to a hundred percent of your
demonstrated need based on the FAFSA
okay so that's an important one needs
sensitive and this is getting to your
point there are schools and again the
great majority of schools are need
sensitive because they have limited
budgets so they might take into account
at some point in the process financial
aid if again if we're sort of talking to
really high achieving low-income
students right now typically they're
still going to make out very well
because even though the school might
take into account need and the student
may need as much as a full ride if
they're a really top top student that's
still somebody they're going to support
and probably pay for if you're a student
that's not as strong that's when you
might get caught in exactly what you're
asking about is oh you need X number of
dollars you're sort of right in you know
a range where we have a lot of choices
that may
make you less attractive so again the
the story I always tell students is the
better student you are not only the more
opportunities we'll have for admission
but the better financial aid packages
you'll be eligible for that's right and
is it is it possible it might even go
the other way where when they look at
your need and they see wow you know this
he he or she comes from a family that
you know didn't have all the resources
of many of our other applicants that
that actually could be a positive when
you when you when you apply oh
absolutely I think the ed for example
Andover operates on a need blind
admission initiative and and we're
looking for students who meet the
demands of our program and when you see
students who may not have had all the
preparation in terms of leading up to
coming to handover it's very compelling
to find students who could manage the
rigor of our program and and not have
had that preparation and so we would we
would be very attractive to them and
want to provide a financial aid package
that supports them at our school
colleges operate the same way and
Phyllis and are obviously you know well
recognized high school and colleges
you're saying are operating in a very
similar way or many do exactly yes they
do
right very cool